hello my name is Matt thanks for tuning
in to my channel here and I wanted to
talk about something interesting that
happened to me when I was googling weird
intro huh I was doing some research on
the mentality of smart people and I know
it sounds weird or well not so much
necessarily be smart people just people
who think the air sports smart and when
I started typing in something about does
thinking you're smart
something something Google started to
autofill in and I found this this
article
um people who think they can get smarter
makes makes him smarter and I was like
well that's Ruthie okay
when I first saw the Google search I
that it recommended it was weird it was
I was a little confused I admit but then
I I came upon the link that it was
referring to and this is back from 2003
from the American Psychological
Association and it is just a little
study they did that basically shows that
if you believe that you can learn you
can there's the link pretty
straightforward or if you just google
search does making does thinking yours
you're smart you know whatever this
title but it is really important I think
it's really important to share okay so
the the main thing is it took two groups
of students and one of them they didn't
say anything to and the other group they
told them hey look you can get smarter
basically and and just gave them some
encouragement to lead them to believe
that they can get smarter and they and
that group did way better than the group
that was told nothing now I have a few
concerns about this such as it doesn't
say how much they talk to the other
group because yeah if you just don't
talk to them at all and you just say
anything you talk to the other other
ones in any way you just ask to ask them
about themselves or something maybe even
I bet you they do better to just just
from being talked to so that's that's
what I wonder about this that isn't
really clear it just says hey we told
one group they could get smarter any
other we didn't say anything to the ones
we told you just smarter got smarter
well what do they do to the other ones
at all did they like give them the
silent treatment
so to speak it doesn't say because I
think that would make them less
encouraged I don't know it's possible
but it's just not a very in-depth a
little thing here there's some cited
research now it looks like it gets into
some racial things
a little bit but it is a pretty old
article okay so I'll just read this what
it says here from the findings of course
and I don't forget to also smash the
buttons to help out this channel alright
let's read these findings can people get
smarter are some so racial or social
groups smarter than others despite a lot
of evidence to the contrary many people
believe that until intelligence is fixed
and moreover that some racial and social
groups are inherently smarter than
others
Merilee evoking these stereotypes about
the intellectual inferiority of these
groups such as women and blacks is not
is enough to harm the academic
performance of members of these groups
social psychologist Claude Steele and
his collaborators 2002 have called this
phenomenon stereotypes threat way many
many believe that intelligence is fixed
and moreover that some racial and social
groups are inherently smarter than
others do people actually believe that
some might some might not okay well
we're way past the date of this article
this is 2003 so this is pretty old
article maybe maybe it's a little dated
in its wording yet psychologists arson
fried and good have developed a possible
antidote to stereotype threat they
taught African American and European
Americans college students to think of
intelligence as changeable rather than
fixed a lesson that many psychological
studies suggest is true students and a
control group did not receive this
message those students who learned about
IQs malleability improved their grades
more than did students who didn't not
receive this message and also saw
academics is more important than
students did then did students in the
control group even more exciting was the
finding that black students benefited
more from learning about the malleable
nature of until
than did white students showing that
this intervention may successfully
counteract stereotype threat what I'm
really will really kind of throws me
back is how do people ever get set in
the mentality that they can't get
smarter you know when you start growing
from a lung lung kid young kid you know
when you're young and growing up
you're very obviously getting smarter
and learning more so why would you
believe that you can't get smarter when
that's what you've been doing your
entire life
where where does anyone ever get the
idea that they can't get smarter that's
where I get stuck I can't figure out how
someone would ever be in the situation
where they think they can't get smarter
given you know there there's some
scenarios maybe there's there are some
conditions regressive conditions that
are you know not under your control
obviously there are some conditions that
make it so it's hard for you to get
smarter but even in those cases you
still can at least a little so what this
is actually saying to me is something
different I think the only way someone
grows up and and starts thinking that
can't get smarter
in also assuming they don't have a
kidney condition they're fine human his
abuse they've been abused that's like an
unfortunate and realization in my head
it does not mention in this article but
how do how do people grow up getting
smarter every day just by nature without
even trying to you know and then somehow
think that it's not possible and let
that tank their grades and everything
and in their performance and ruin their
life and and if if you somehow believe
that you can't get smarter you probably
have a bit of a mental problem and it's
probably not even your fault it's
probably the fault of the people you're
growing up around maybe or whoever's
talking to you whoever saying things
like you're a little [ __ ] you're useless
you know think whoever that is that's
the person that is guilty of the said
abuse and this goes in many different
directions it's just a general we live
in a in a strange world and I guess this
is a really relevant to all the riots
and stuff you know all of that's all
about mistreatment too is it just all
coming to a head now is the world
finally realizing oh we actually do have
to be nice to each other
we can't just like [ __ ] on each other
every day and expect everyone to get
better for it so countries get along for
real like stop abusing each other that's
it that goes for everyone in all
directions you're all responsible for
yourselves on that no one can force you
to do anything they are that's probably
wrong you're still making the ultimate
decision to follow them or not so be
true to yourselves be good to each other
peace out